alors justin trudeau et qui est en ville
avec pas mal de libéro d'un peu partout
au canada congrès de trois jours qui se
tient au palais des congrès de montréal
on va rejoindre emmanuelle latraverse
emmanuel on a en a vu hier monsieur
trudeau donc qui a attaqué la charte des
valeurs ça c'était pas nouveau mais il
l'a fait de façon peut-être encore plus
frontale de façon générale vous sentez
les libéraux fédéraux assez gonflé assez
confiant oui on a beaucoup de congrès
libéraux dans les dernières années où l
ambiance était très morose écouter ici
c'est pas ça du tout les délégués sont
enthousiastes ils sont très mobilisés je
vous dirais ils ont confiance dans les
chances de leur chef
faudrait que le clou de ce de ce congrès
la inévitablement ce sera le discours de
justin trudeau demain alors que lui doit
vraiment commencé à étoffer sa vision
politique faire la preuve qu'il a une
solution pour générer la fameuse
croissance économique qui serait
nécessaire pour résoudre les maux de la
classe moyenne ce sera le vrai test de
ce congrès là mais plus largement c'est
aussi un congrès qui vise à consacrer je
vous dirais le changement de garde au
parti libéral tant au niveau de
l'organisation au niveau 1 des futurs
candidats des gens qu'on recrute et
atteint chapitre il y avait une certaine
bâton deux discours qui ont été
prononcées aujourd'hui sur le plancher
du congrès et auquel justin trudeau a
assisté qui illustrait ça par exemple
l'ancienne directrice adjoint de la
campagne de barack obama en 2012 est
venu exposer si vous voulez la recette
organisationnel que e.on revenus et que
subit fonctionner d'une certaine façon
un jour j'aurai temps de vous exposer la
technique du flocon vous allez fatigué
clown ont évolué et un autre un autre
bien sûr c'était celui du général à la
retraite andrew leslie qu'est vraiment
la star des libéraux en ce moment
conseiller à la défense de justin
trudeau éventuel éventuel cancan
candidats pour lui donc tout ça pour
montrer qu'il est capable de s'entourer
de sang neuf mais justement parlons de
général leslie est intéressant parce que
voilà il s'est adressé aux libéraux mais
a répondu conservateurs qui ont mené une
charge contre lui à propos de frais
de déménagement bref lui a l'impression
que parce qu'il est devenu libéral et
mais n'est plus générale les
conservateurs l'attaquent
c'est ce qu'il a plaidé dans son
discours je vous dirais lui qui soutient
que les fameux frais de déménagement la
cli conservateurs ont tant dénoncées
faisaient partie d'un programme qui est
offert à tous les militaires qui
prennent leur retraite
l'eau ça s'est gâté je vous dirais c'est
que lui bon soutient qu'il est puni par
les conservateurs pour avoir choisi le
parti libéral plutôt que les avoir
choisis eux mais ce qui est ressorti de
tout ça aussi c'est finalement une jolie
fille un peu magazine et son parti
politique les conservateurs disent que
lui-même les eaux approché et lui
refusent de clarifier si vous voulez la
situation se contente de dire que des
discussions avec tout le monde que ce
qui compte finalement dit qu'il est
choisi
justin trudeau mais morale de l'histoire
ça ternit le lustre de sa candidature
parce que celui qui avait l'air d'être
si loyal l'air aussi d'un mercenaire en
politique entre les seringues des
candidats vedettes de justin trudeau un
mot je vous donne 10 secondes
mélanie joly était là elle est venue
faire un petit tour mais elle continue à
dire que c'est montréal qu'elle aime
c'est ce qu'elle dit qui est pas
question pour elle de faire le saut en
politique fédérale
mais je pourrais vous dire que il ya
aucun organisateur libéral ici qui seul
est découragée 2015 c'est encore loin
d'ici salut emmanuel à la poche et un au
revoir bon congrès